trotzdem passiert 40 wie in einer
schlechten tv soap an
der vater hat sich sehr früh sex
geschnappt jetzt ist es zu viel für mich
herz bekommt da wir dort haben wir heute
einen kleinen ausflug machen werden denn
das video anschauen werden spielt nicht
in deutschland ich hab mir nämlich
gedacht leute was mach ich häufig im
video und dann habe ich unter anderem
natürlich auch und wir sind dort um hilf
mir kanal vorbeigeschaut und habe ich
gemerkt
wisst ihr was ich habe eigentlich gerade
gar keinen bock mehr hilft mir also
schon gute sache für mich das ist das
ist teilweise situationen gibt die echt
sind aber quasi wie hilft mir aussehen
ich bin da möchte ich den tipp von einem
zuschauer auf das video gestoßen was
tatsächlich den titel hat das ist kein
häfen halte ich das für august ist
nämlich ihre hilfen wieder was ist kein
das sicher heißt es mit dem ex luxus der
die spannend tochter den freund aus und
wie gesagt wir suchen hier das hilfen im
zeichen vergeben ist das hier ist ein
beitrag von taff also es ist wirklich
passiert
wie startet jetzt die leute und vorneweg
möchte ich noch mal sagen leute von
ganzem herzen vielen vielen dank für den
support in den letzten tagen es waren
einige der erfolgreichsten wochen die
ich jemals auf einem kanal hatte in
sechs oder sieben jahren mittlerweile
600 tausend abonnenten auch geknackt
kurs geht raus an jeden einzelnen von
euch und dass man nicht wirklich ernst
und ja herzlich alle prunk protz
womöglich hat er bald ein ende und
safran der wohl verrückteste teenager
der welt ein probeliegen
ok also kurzinfo vorweg diese diese frau
ist glaube ich schon mal einem topf
beitrag aufgetreten das weiß ich glaube
ich nicht weil ich darauf reagiert habe
aber weil ich den immer am rande mal
gesehen habe da ich dieses mädchen heißt
das heißt software also saf ffo da ist
schon alles vorbei weiß eigentlich schon
ganz genau was abgeht wie könnt ihr
vergessen diesen bekannte sich das video
5000 euro sind zu wenig taschengeld
dieser frau ist der verwöhntesten
teenager der welt habt ihr also frauen
scheint als würde die mitgliedschaft
eine familie jetzt gerade beck feiern
ich habe schon alles von der sie
bekommen nicht denn ich will alles das
alles mal ein also sie hat scheinbar 22
väter also ihre väter sind schwul
miteinander haben geheiratet kinder
adoptiert kinder gezeugt wahrscheinlich
nicht wird wahrscheinlich schwer
aber schauen wir uns kurz dieses bild an
ja denkt ihr dass ich mich auch was für
ein kronleuchter
ich stoppe mal ganz kurz bewerb kurzer
blick in den kommentaren da sind so
geile kommentare zu ihrem aussehen dabei
frieses der bericht macht nicht schön
und auch nicht schlau von surprise die
sieht aus wie ein zusammengequetscht
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
pech nur dass es für die einzige tochter
zweier millionenschwerer fifa gerade
knüppeldick kommt ihre teddys sind
frisch getrennt genau wie sein 75 hat
sich einer ihrer frisch geschiedene
väter gedacht moment ich bin single und
willst so angekommen dass meine tochter
sie auch gerade von ihrem freund
getrennt hat dann schaue ich mir doch
einfach
also sorry aber ganz ehrlich da kannst
du mir so viel taschengeld geben wie du
willst mit 20.000 euro taschengeld im
monat geben würde ich nicht machen wenn
nicht im gegenzug dafür ist von
geisteskranken vater bekommen
übrigens sollte ganz kurz wurde letztens
schon kritisiert dass ich mir zu oft ans
ohr fassen würde und das liegt aber
daran dass die kopfhörer wir leider
nicht so gut halten
das wundert damit dass es keine keine
flex methode was dann passiert wird sich
wie in einer schlechten tv soap an der
alten vater hat sich sehr früh sex
geschnappt
das ist die ganze sache würde ich jetzt
eigentlich sagen wollen aber das
schlimme ist die sache ist ja ausgedacht
wir haben sie ja zusammengeklappt der
angry birds ja und ihr vater der ihr
gegenüber steht und einfach packen
dreist vor gesteht mit ihrem ex-freund
müssen so jung muss jetzt kommt didier
ist hoffentlich bewusst dass sollten uns
gott und ich heiraten er den stiefvater
wird das will ich nie wieder hören
ok sehr natürlicher austausch war nicht
gestellt leute das ist noch nicht
gestellt hallo im fernsehbild nichts
gestellt
aber mal ganz davon abgesehen leute also
auch wenn das gestellt ist was was ist
das für eine aussage dem eigenen kind
gegenüber also du musst schon den
kompletten bastelten ruf und kommst mit
dem exfreund von einer ein kind zusammen
so brauch was ist falsch mit dir
und dann bleibt es jedoch noch so
richtig unter die nase ok so schön die
riedbahn schmoldt und das gewaltig der
grund macht sie doch permanent oder
stunde das geht überhaupt nicht das war
ihr lover scott ihr den laufpass gegeben
und bereits eine neue flamme hat
ausgerechnet de france vater barry
schlimmer kann es für die 20 jährige
kaum kommen also es ist wirklich so man
fasst sich an den kopf und man schaut
kurz konnte man scrollt kurz runter und
denkt sich so dicke dinger das tier
nicht hilf mir
der chef sich also so echt wie also
scharf beiträge sind weiß man auch nicht
genau aber zumindest ein bisschen recht
hätte 2 aber leute ihr wisst ihr wissen
scheiterte ich hänge mich zu sehr an
solchen sachen auf ich habe irgendwie
auch im hinterkopf so ein bild zu tun
hat eine menge liebe hat sie doch mega
ähnlich ich muss mir keiner was war
sondern übersicht von den angry birds
reinziehen dass ich sehe welche vogel
von denen das ist weil einem sieht dies
ähnlich
wirst du dich so geile ein
zusammengeklappt da englisch oder aber
ich weiß es aber nicht so genau das ist
schwierig das dass das zu ordern
ich finde sie sieht eigentlich diesen
schwarzen damen ihren nichten oder oder
mit dem schwarzen ihrer dem normalen
roten aber ich weiß nicht genau wie
schreibt man die kommentare was ihr
denkt welcher ich war schon extrem
schockiert und sicher setzt mir das zu
doch das herz gebrochen hat es mir nicht
ganz einfach weil es kommt mehr ohne
chemie besonders viel bedeutet hat
folglich ist das egal
[Musik]
hey leute was ist dein leben halte dir
das mal vor augen sie hat irgendwie also
mal angenommen dass das wirklich in
diese familie so passiert das ist ein
echter fall ist was was passiert als
nächstes in so einer familie die sie vom
fernsehen begleitet wird nichtmal wann
man wird nicht in diesem gespräch redet
miteinander so ich hab wirklich was ganz
tolles gemacht aber ich muss dir
beichten nein als allererstes würde es
hat prosieben eingestellt daher wird es
alles vor laufender kamera kann mir doch
kein mensch erzählen dass sie wirklich
so leben dass mit cr9 scott hat nie so
wirklich funktioniert aber dass gott und
ich warum nicht mal sehen wie es läuft
das mit der tochter hat nicht so gut
funktioniert und dann hat er sich
gedacht ja dann kümmere ich mich
manchmal was ich da irgendwann einmal
mehr geben die schräg stellen durch
baris den begriff abgehoben
neue dimension doch einmal scheint das
mehr als alle anderen
ich kann dich nicht neutral bleiben also
welches gesicht sehe ja ja
oberflächlichen haben aber was sind ihre
also denkt ihr euch so hammer ich bin
neues auto ich finde das steht mir jetzt
hast du einen stuhl hat sie ein neues
auto verdient nein ich bin immer noch
deine tochter ist das echte leben
es ist dass das echte leben sagen dass
irgendwo auf der welt so sein leben lebt
also die tochter kommt einfach so mit
nachtrag zum kurz am café das ganze papa
stück kuchen reingehauen
in den schlachten mit so kommt sie ihrem
vater leitet aber ich will neues auto
ich finde ich habe das verdient erster
fehler der stelle direkt eine klatsche
für seine aussage womit hast es verdient
dass das der vater überhaupt diese
aussage zulässt und dann auch noch
seinen neuen freund der der export
seiner tochter ist fragt nach rat und
der dann nein sagt also das bringe kann
das nicht irgendwie auf einen nenner
bringen das ist einfach geisteskrank
eine familie fernab aller normalität und
so reich dass ihr lifestyle konsequent
alle grenzen der vernunft steigt okay
heute mal kurz an der stelle also ja es
ist ja kein geheimnis dass man auch
teilweise mit youtube nicht ganz
schlecht verdient so eindeutig selbst
kein ganzes leben von dem was ich so
mache ich kenne auch viele leute die
sehr sehr reich damit tatsächlich
geworden sind auch hier in deutschland
aber leute wirklich dass das coolste
eigentlich wenn man viel geld hat ist
trotzdem noch halbwegs normal zu sein
das echte school zu wasser machen kann
so viele leute habe ich jetzt auch
persönlich mal im umfeld gesehen drehen
einfach geisteskrank ab und denkt auf
einmal sie sind keine ahnung david
beckham oder sind etwas besseres und
flexen nur noch dumm den ganzen tag lang
wobei ich auch ganz selbstkritisch sagen
muss dass ich auch manchmal solche flex
phasen habe aber wie gesagt cool ist es
nicht bekommt ein taschengeld von 5000
euro monatlich und damit darf sie sich
kaufen was immer sie braucht oder will
all die kleinigkeiten die man halt so
benötigt viel zu wenig viel zu wenig
taschengeld aber das haben wir alles
schon in dem video beitrag den ich hatte
schon geahnt habe schon gesehen
andererseits pro was geht mit der haut
von dem linken typen ab dicker der sieht
aus wie eine rindswurst die gerade
frisch aus der pfanne kommt ja leute
also ich kann viel von mir selbst sagen
beta keinen bock in so einer plastik von
mir zu leben aber vielleicht habt ihr
lust war ihr denkt okay dann kann ich
mir das leisten könne man den
kommentaren schreibt check auf jeden
fall hier drüben ein vorgeschlagenes
video habt und abonnieren
ein kanal damit wir uns auf dem weg zu
700 km machen können sie mich sehr
freuen
ich bin jetzt daraus kurs für 600
[Musik]